est-ce qu'il n'est pas totalement coincé
de tous les côtés ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui il se dit qu'il faut confier
mais on le coince encore oui c'est un
triangle dans lequel il est prisonnier
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas gagner
sur tous les tableaux
si on gagne sur le tableau sanitaire en
construisant on perd sur le tableau
économique avec les faillites qui vont
se multiplier
s'ils ont des consignes trop tôt et bien
on repère sur le côté sanitaire et puis
limiter les libertés personne ne va y
gagner ça c'est une certitude on ne
gagne jamais alinéa limiter les libertés
et là on se rend compte que c'est un
gouvernement qui est très conscient
aussi de sa responsabilité
on a des gens aux commandes qui
finalement était ministre premier
ministre président qui faisait ça parce
que ça fait bien sur un cv parce que ça
permet aussi de faire avancer un agenda
qui est le même depuis des années la
mondialisation heureuse davantage
d'inégalités libérer les énergies et
puis quand arrive une crise est bien
être politique c'est être responsable
hélas la case responsabilités ils
veulent surtout pas la cocher est
maintenant beaucoup de leur temps en
fait utilisé à éviter la responsabilité
de sortie de crise en disant j'ai fait
ce que je pouvais mais je ne pouvais pas
faire autrement
regarder à côté ils n'ont pas fait mieux
et puis que vous auriez fait quoi à ma
place mais à notre à leur place on
aurait peut-être simplement suivi le ms
on aurait peut-être au lieu de mentir
dès le début en disant qu'ils avaient
suffisamment de masques y avait pas de
pénurie de masques
ce sont les mots de jérôme ça le mot ce
sont des mots d agnès buzyn ce sont les
mots d'olivier ferrand qu'il refusait de
parler pnue qui refusait de dire que le
masque était utile qui ont même changé
la doctrine il y avait une doctrine de
pandémie à propos du h1n1 ou le masque
était obligatoire nécessaires notamment
dans les métiers de contact et bien
qu'est ce que fait la république en
marche ils réécrivent une doctrine à la
va-vite en janvier pour griller gommer
les masques de cette nouvelle doctrine
sur le kobe de 19 ans disant finalement
les masques c'est uniquement pour les
soignants et les malades donc ce
gouvernement du mensonge c'est normal
que ça leur pète à la gueule excusez moi
de l'expression
maintenant il faut assumer or le
problème c'est qu'ils refusent les
responsabilités c'est toujours la même
case un responsable mais pas coupable
et bien si ils sont irresponsables et
sans doute coupable
l'enquète les enquêtes avec plein de
vide et d'autres feront la lumière sur
les responsabilités et la culpabilité
des uns et les autres
[Musique]